all right guys
bang bang lunch money time well while
she's trying to get rich for us let's
just trying to get our lunch money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
paulina
guess what i got a haircut yesterday she
didn't get a haircut yesterday that's
not what i'm
telling people to guess today is
september 11th
which is not a good day in history but
it is also
two months one two months since we got
married
so this is like a two month anniversary
she thought that i didn't remember but i
did remember
i'm glad you did are you impressed yes
but he ate one of my chocolates
yesterday that's a whole nother refer to
my twitter no problem
uh so in case anyone wants to know block
five is a sponsor you should go download
block pi or sign up for an account
you can go to blackfy.com pomp they have
a interest bearing account 8.6 apy no
brainer
uh they also have a
uh crypto exchange where you can buy and
sell crypto and they also have
a place where you can get a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
wifi.com what's up hey what's going on
happy anniversary the first topic
is rollins okay all right
you want to tell us what's rolling these
days
um no i don't want to tell them he has
an announcement
he has a new fund that roles
tell them i announced this morning i'm
watching a new fund
it rules anybody anybody who's an
accredited investor
can invest in it i'll put the link in
the description you can anyone who wants
they can invest who's in the executive
credit investor
it's all early stage uh venture capital
investments
but go check it out that's it what's the
next topic
big date for you today just because
we'll see how it goes our anniversary
monthiversary
oh my god we're so disgusting i hate it
okay so there's only one person who's
serious here
peloton i'm not serious go ahead hello
todd what's up with hello
please he's wearing the profile shirt
i'm wearing a love shirt
okay peloton
for peloton the pandemic has been
profitable the at-home fitness company
announced its first ever quarterly
profit which was bolstered by a 172
percent
surge in sales and more than 1 million
people
subscribing to its streaming classes i
remember a time where everybody was
super skeptical of peloton and saying
like
you're selling really expensive pieces
of equipment this is never going to
scale this is never going to work
and here we are covet everybody got a
peloton
yeah i mean look this makes a ton of
sense uh from my standpoint
um peloton's one of those companies
that's really hard to put in a box so
yes they have a piece of hardware yes
they have software they
put it in a box and they deliver no but
no then they've got subscription
software right
but also like it's kind of like a club
or like people feel like oh do you have
a peloton like there's a leaderboard
they race there's a community around it
they probably could sell merchandise
like there's all kinds of
things around this company um so yes
it's an at-home
kind of workout fitness thing but it's
also kind of like a social network
should we get a peloton no absolutely
not uh
so it doesn't surprise me that they're
doing well especially with the pandemic
all that kind of stuff uh what's going
to be really interesting and i think
they've already started to come out with
other types of products but that to me
is going to be the big uh
question is how big can this get can
they eat the entire
gym meaning that can they go you know uh
machinery by machinery and kind of
replace all the pieces of machine
maybe it's pretty difficult yeah
we'll see all right what's next next
is um okay so you know how instagram
launched wheels
last month um as the u.s looked to ban
tick tock
basically adam how do you say it mossari
yeah adam missouri siri the head of
instagram said any short-term benefit
that instagram would see from a
potential tick-tock ban
is greatly outweighed by the risks of a
fragmented internet
so he's not about the ban yeah he's not
celebrating adam
uh morsi is uh mossery i'm siri
i worked with him at facebook okay but
you just pronounced it two different
ways
i'm sorry uh he's incredibly intelligent
like i remember uh multiple times being
like dude that guy is really really
smart
uh so it does not surprise me that he's
running instagram now uh i think at the
time he's running like news feed or
something
um and i actually agree with him like
you don't want to operate in a world
where the internet becomes super siloed
right he said if it benefits us in the
short term in terms of slowing down a
competitor
the precedent it sets for us is much
much worse for us as a business in the
long term
because if it happens to tick tock it
can easily happen to them right
that was he that is what he's saying
of course and so i think that the the
big thing here
really comes down to uh
instagram and facebook they don't really
have a say obviously like maybe they can
influence or do something like that but
they don't have a say over whether tick
tock actually gets banned
it's more of just that you have to be
reactive to it um and so we'll uh
we'll kind of see how this plays out but
also
reels on instagram i haven't seen any
i i mean like i've seen a few but
they're not catching on i'm sorry
no they're not yes they are yes they are
you want to bet when when they do the
next quarterly
update where they give uh data points
i'm not seeing it on my timeline
therefore it is not catching up
okay no problem
i'm glad polina's not a traitor who
makes decisions based on her timeline
yesterday
i asked him what he's learned in two
months of marriage and he said
whatever paulina wants yeah
that's not a lesson no that is a lesson
no it's not
i don't argue it's very smart advice
any men out there if you're married or
you have a girlfriend
i'm only two months in but let me give
you a big big piece of advice
just go with the flow
she wants to do something sure she
doesn't want to do something
sure she doesn't see it in her feet so
it's not catching up
sure hey it's catching on
you're right what's the last wheel you
saw that stuck in your head
uh i saw this guy he was sitting there
at the dinner table and you know on
tick-tock how they take
in the car they take the bag and they
whack people yeah or whatever
yeah i saw one uh on uh reels and the
guy who sit there he just went like this
and he kept doing it at the dinner table
okay so they're copying tick tock
wow no it's me copying all right what's
next
facebook speaking of instagram facebook
is getting back to its roots
as a college-focused social network the
company announced today
the launch of a new social networking
platform called facebook
campus which offers college students a
private place to connect with classmates
join groups discover upcoming
campus events get updates from their
school's administration and chat with
other students
from their dorm clubs or any other
campus group you gotta have a
edu account to sign up for this that's
interesting
they're getting back to their roots are
professors allowed in
probably so i mean the school's
administration can send updates and
stuff
oh so the school basically they're
trying to it's like the workplace it's
like workplace software but instead
they're trying to go after
colleges okay so it's not like really a
social network
it's more of uh just like they have a
facebook at work or work at facebook or
whatever they call it
uh but you can get your like you know
your class updates all that kind of
stuff you can meet people in your dorm
so it's kind of a social network
or alternatively you can just go and
knock on their door or like
they leave their door okay serial killer
i made many friends in my freshman dorm
yeah i'm sure you did
hello i would like to introduce myself
i'm the nerd i have cookies
on 3c
all right what's next nerd
i'm trying to remember my room number
come on let's go okay
um sorry google okay google
uh announced it has a multi-year deal to
provide its cloud services to sofi
stadium and the hollywood park
campus google hopes that these sorts of
sports deals will help it regain
traction against amazon and microsoft so
basically um
it's powering google's cloud services
will help power all the data passing
through the state-of-the-art sofi
stadium
and will provide a new personal
concierge draft that offers real-time
metrics on game day
supposed to be super futuristic they
have the bit the largest scoreboard
ever it's a 300 foot 4k
oculus scoreboard so what like
google's just gonna be like here's some
data like here's what you need to know
yeah i mean look google's got this
massive cloud business obviously amazon
does as well
uh they basically compete with each
other but it's just a tax i mean that's
all that they're doing
is right is they've basically created a
way for they can tax every business in
the world who needs cloud services
they've got to go through google and
amazon
uh and other large cloud providers right
so i mean it's a five billion dollar
complex where
five billion dollar complex uh yeah i
mean this makes a lot of sense and
and look they're just saying that they
basically picked them to
serve their technology needs well
there's only like four people you could
have picked
right so google being the winner i mean
they won the sweepstakes if you will
but it's not like you know there was a
hundred people to pick from in my
opinion
all right ready for the next one my
head's cut off a little bit
well don't say i have a big head because
i will come after you
okay like an oblong head
oblong hey you know the shape that is
you're oblong it's like uh no people are
going to be talking about my head shape
i get enough of that yeah you got an egg
head you're an egghead now you look like
an egghead
okay conehead that's what they are
remember your cone heads
all right come on let's go i got things
to do today
conehead i'm in so much trouble when we
get done with this but that's okay nasa
is officially in the market for moon
rocks and it's willing to pay
any company that's capable of scooping
them up
today the space agency is putting out a
call for proposals from companies
challenging them to snag small samples
of rocks on the moon's surface
the companies will have to prove that
they have collected lunar samples
in some kind of small container by
sending pictures and data to nasa
if satisfied nasa pledges to purchase
the sample
samples for between fifteen thousand and
twenty five thousand dollars
how many companies can go to the moon
don't you kind of have to work with
nasa to like go to the moon they're
basically like oh if you just go
like you just could walk outside anybody
who picks up rocks will buy them from
for only
and i would like imagine going through
the trouble to figure out one how to
even get to the moon to like pick up
some rocks and you only get fifteen
thousand dollars i'd be
pissed with my oblong head i'd be pissed
i just what are there five companies
that can go to the moon
maybe they have like i mean technically
technically spacex never has never gone
to the moon
that's wild right i'm pretty sure that's
correct if i'm wrong somebody correct me
but
i don't think that spacex ever gone to
the moon it's a small first step toward
creating a lunar marketplace
yeah if nasa is paying other companies
and nasa is not going to get them who
else is going to get the movement right
now
wild maybe what they're just trying to
do is
maybe they're just trying to create the
demand side of the marketplace and then
they'll also go do the supply side like
an early stage startup who's got a
two-sided marketplace you know
just control one side of it yeah cool
ready for my joke
don't look yeah i thought the joke was
already happened no
why are good-looking people always busy
because they're not busted
no i would tell you but i'm busy right
now
with my long head say it again i said
i could tell you why but i'm busy right
now um
the best way to buy a mirror is through
self-checkout
guys that might be the first time she's
ever said a joke and i
know it's true okay or maybe i was
laughing because it's not true
let's go just kidding you gotta follow
your own advice
what is my own advice everything just
agree with me
this is how our this is how we argue i
say but and she goes no you're supposed
to just agree with me
okay no problem all right guys that's it
for lunch monday well while she's trying
to get rich russell's just trying to get
her lunch money right we'll see you on
monday
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends